what is your take right now we're at 60
000 almost 61 000 bitcoin what's your
general read on the market
no look this is this is incredible last
night pomp called me about 11 o'clock i
was going siesta time but he got me up
got the pizza back out got online um i
think this etf stuff is really
interesting i'm not quite sure how it's
going to play out like i'm a little
worried that it's going to be kind of
the sell the news um
situation but that's not happening right
now i think there's a number of other
etfs that are going to come on the back
of this announcement next week which i
think is really cool
um still super bullish going into the
end of the year six figure bitcoin
bitcoins on the way
um and uh nah man i think uh everything
that could happen to set this up has
kind of happened it's not great uh
because um you know bitcoin kind of
works if some other things are breaking
but here we are so when you think about
uh all of the institutions you and i
talked to i have no clue how many
hundreds of institutions over the years
and
all of them were
along the spectrum of i'm not interested
at all that sounds stupid you guys are
crazy two
that's interesting but i can't invest
two there was a couple of very very
forward-thinking institutions that
decided they were going to allocate to
it but outside of the forward-thinking
ones the rest of the market they're
basically showing up now how do you
think about the fact that they could
have bought at a much lower price now
they're buying around you know 40 50 60
000
is that just a a function of you kind of
buy the price of bitcoin that you
deserve
yeah exactly and i you know i hadn't
talked to you or prepared for this but i
do want to call out something because
you won't do it
you spent a lot of time educating people
pomp and one person in particular that
really broke my heart recently was jim
cramer because i'm kind of a fan of the
mad money guy he's kind of wacky
and you brought him into bitcoin spent a
lot of time with him and i think he
bought bitcoin around 12 000 and i was
so happy for him he had this evolution
of thought he kind of ditched the whole
boomer stuff
and uh got rid of the gold stuff you
know peter schiff he parked all of that
and off we went
i think he sold and paper-handed bitcoin
around 60k 62k and paid off his mortgage
um absolute disaster of a situation
happy to expand on it with you guys but
man that was a heartbreaking situation
shame on you jim cramer shame on you jim
cramer
what do you think about uh the norell
norbini's uh the peter schiffs kind of
the crowd that's built an entire
reputation around being a bear
look
the bubble gang nouriel roubini or
roubini room and beanie whatever the
last name is i don't know where you are
i'm looking for you i've been looking
for you for a while you called me out
said i worked in some starbucks bathroom
with pomp raising money don't even get
me started on the performance of that
fun son
now
peter schiff
where are you
i went on fox news talking to you you're
talking about gold this gold that gold
is nothing gold's a mess
bitcoin come at me son what did get me
on fox news what did peter schiff say to
you on fox news
i don't know he was just kept talking
over me about gold and bitcoins not
backed by anything you know it's a
speculative i'm a punter i'm i'm a
horticulturist you know they're talking
about things i don't understand and
tulips i don't deal with tulips i never
had a tulip in my life pomp never won
but what i do is i got bitcoin and i got
the belt son what is the interest bill
all right what is the belt oh it's the
interest champ belt uh-huh yes sir what
are you you don't know what this is
you ain't in this game making this
interest that i make son you don't
understand
i don't understand i've been getting
explain how you got the interest jam
belt
[Laughter]
now this was back this was back when
bitcoin was really suffering man i was
in uh peru
um in march earl march uh 2020 i had
parked a bunch of money at blockfy in um
in a stablecoin and i was just sitting
on it collecting interest uh waiting for
an opportunity and the opportunity came
bitcoin was like
four thousand dollars
and i had a few natty lights
waves were good i was with my boys and i
started smash buying millions millions
of dollars worth of bitcoin at around
four thousand and then the whole world
burned down i got back to the u.s right
before they closed the borders and stuff
and the next the kind of 15 months were
horrible but uh look who's laughing now
you know who else is laughing
bitcoin just crossed 61 000 while we're
on here if we just stay on this live
chat on this uh live stream we may cross
64 000 before we get off 61 200.
yeah look you know i i'm not here to
teach anyone anything i just want to
show people what winning looks like